The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I'm
going to combine these two
pieces together because
they're obviously
have a lot of overlap.
AUDIENCE: Would you mind
talking about innovation?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Isn't that the course?
Wait a minute.
AUDIENCE: Good point.
So Berger and the
Jonas Nahm reading
talked about how
learning takes place
at all points in
the design cycle
and how we're not
really linking games.
Well, I know you're about to
talk about this now, but--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I promise.
AUDIENCE: --we talked about
how basically the United
States didn't concede with
innovation as existing
in manufacturing.
Will you hit on that now?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I mean I can do that
now, and it's not really
in either of these readings.
Briefly in the decline of
US manufacturing reading.
We'll talk about this
in depth next week
when we dive into the origins
of the US innovation system
where it came from.
Where did the R&D
agencies come from?
But in essence, when
the US is constructing,
its innovation system in
the course of World War
II and the immediate aftermath.
And we'll read Vannevar Bush
and talk about him next week.
Before the Second World
War, the US wasn't all that
strong a science power.
There were countries
like Germany and Britain
that were considerably
further ahead
by general world view in
science capability than the US.
And Vannevar Bush worked
hard during World War II
to build up that early
stage research capability
and then link it to
more applied stations
of the course of the war.
At the end of the
war, he has a choice.
What do we save?
And he decides as the
war is winding down--
and we'll talk about
this next week.
--he decides to save
that early stage research
capability because that
was what the problem was.
The United States was
king of manufacturing.
Manufacturing production
capability in the United States
dwarfed every other country,
including our two major postwar
or pre-war competitors,
Germany and Japan.
We just had much bigger
production capability.
We had developed mass
production we would read.
No one else had figured out,
in part because we could sell
into a continent size economy.
We created the first continent
sized industrial economy,
and we could sell into that.
So production
wasn't the problem.
We completely
dominated production.
It never occurred
to anybody in the US
that there might come a
challenge to US production
capability.
Instead the problem Vannevar
Bush is trying to solve
is building this early
stage research capability,
which we didn't really
have that strong
a system prior to the war.
So the US innovation
system when it gets
created in that
post-war period--
and we'll go into
this next week.
--doesn't focus on production
because it's not a problem.
In countries like
Germany and Japan--
which by the way, we had just
bombed their production system.
They've got to restore all that.
They've got to rebuild that.
They develop innovation systems
that are focused on production.
That's where they focus
the innovation systems.
Not like the US does.
We think R&D is king.
Other countries assume this link
between research and production
and focus on the
production stage
because it is indeed
highly innovative.
We just are organizing our
economy very differently.
We miss that, and the
results are painful.
Does that answer more or less?
You can keep pushing on
that too as we go further.
Martin?
AUDIENCE: First, I was going
to ask, you spend a lot of time
watching each other.
How willing are
politicians to listen
to you or people that are
more educated on the matter?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh.
They're on the phone all
the time to me Martin.
Believe it, it's unbearable.
It's constant.
You heard my cell phone going
off through the entire class.
No.
This is only a set
of realizations
that the political system
is starting to come to.
And it's been a
painful set of lessons.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the line period?
So politicians are just
starting to figure it out.
When did you figure, or like
people that are better--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well, I was
lucky enough to hang out in MIT
and get educated by
people like Suzanne Berger
and a series of other terrific
MIT folks who began teaching me
what had been going on here.
So I was a beneficiary
of the MIT fire hose.
I get to stand in it for a
significant period of time.
And so my next book will
be on manufacturing.
So a lot of the snippets
that you're seeing here
will be carried over
into that book which
MIT Press is publishing.
I mean why it takes a year to
process a book even though you
submit it online is beyond me.
But it will come out around
December of this coming year.
But let's go back
into our story.
I should add one
more thing, Martin.
Donald Trump just won the
election on these issues.
This is a lesson that
is now being learned
by the political system.
Are they going to come to the
right conclusions about what
to do about the right policies?
I don't know.
But this is now embedded into
the political learning lessons.
So hollowing out.
I argue that's what the
story has been on employment,
and manufacturing was
down almost a third
in the decade of the 2000s.
It fell to 11.5 or 11.8 I guess,
and it's now back at 12.3,
but that's not that far back.
It was 17 before all this
started, millions of jobs.
Investment.
Manufacturing fixed
capital investment declined
in the 2000s for
the first time when
we started collecting the data,
an actual decline in that time
period.
So in part, as a
result, output is down.
If you're not investing in
capital planning equipment,
what's going to
happen to output?
So output was down
in, depending on how
he counts, either 15 or 16
of the manufacturing sectors
that the government measures.
And then, if output
is lower than assumed,
then productivity is going
to be lower than assumed--
as we discussed before.
So this is the documentation
of the very sharp decline
in manufacturing employment.
In that time period,
from here to here.
So you see what happened.
This is national R&D intensity.
Right?
So this is all related to your
investments in innovation,
although the lag
time is significant.
So here's the R&D intensity
of the US economy.
GDP expenditures as
a percentage of--
gross R&D expenditures
as a percentage of GDP.
This is-- we saw this earlier--
this is the trade balance
for high technology
goods versus all
manufactured products.
Huge deficit in all
manufactured goods in the US.
Increasing deficit in
advanced technology goods.
Are you going to make
this up on services?
Well, services
have been growing.
But look at that growth
rate compared to the fall
out in the goods balance.
Now, this good
balance gets better
because, in the recession,
we're not producing anything.
So, therefore, we're we
aren't buying anything.
But that's the real number,
and we're back to that range
again--
in this time period.
So as you can see, even
if we're staggeringly
successful in services,
it's not going
to offset the balance in goods.
AUDIENCE: What's that
random blip that [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: That's 9/11.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, that's 9/11.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, why did
the services increase?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I have no idea.
I'd have to look at that.
We certainly weren't flying
many airplanes that week.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'll
have to take a look.
So we'd been assuming,
as I said earlier,
that we'd been losing
manufacturing jobs because
of productivity gains.
But that just really
has not been the story.
And this means, then,
that we're not just
going through a normal
business cycle here.
There's real structural
effects here.
Right?
And we're not going to get
out of this by just coming out
of a normal business cycle.
In fact, we didn't get
out of it by coming out
of a normal business cycle.
These manufacturing jobs
are not coming back--
they're gone.
Therefore, you've got not
a business cycle problem,
but a structural problem.
This is percentage loss in
manufacturing jobs between 2000
and 2010, by state.
So the green states
lost 30% to 40%
of their manufacturing jobs.
The purple states lost over 40%
So think of what was going
on in textiles and furniture
in North Carolina, or the
auto sector in Michigan.
But the overall picture--
it's not a pretty
picture, nationwide.
So we've had, kind of,
an American Brexit here,
with a lot of social disruption.
So the manufacturing
decline tended
to create societal decline.
So when we lost a third of
the manufacturing jobs--
historically, manufacturing
was an important middle-class
pathway for, particularly,
high school educated males.
But full employment--
full-year employment
for men with high school,
but not college, degrees
went from 76% in 1990
down to 68% in 2013.
In other words, we
may have unemployment
now back to 4.9%,
which is terrific news.
But we don't count
this structural decline
of people who, in effect,
have left the workforce--
which is still there, as
a deep structural problem.
So the share of men
that did not work at all
in that time period--
with that level of education--
went from 11% in 1990
to 18% in 2013, which is a
pretty staggering number.
Most importantly, you
can't measure this stuff
by average income.
You've got to measure
it by median income
because the gains of
the upper middle class
disguise the decline in
the other income quintiles.
So you've got to look
at median income.
Median income of men, with
no high school diploma,
fell 20% between 1990 and 2013.
And men with a high school
diploma, or some college,
fell 13%.
So there's a growing income
split between college
and non-college educated--
and a major accompanying
rise in income inequality.
So David Otter's picture
of this is of a barbell.
And one of the bells--
and Beth could tell us this--
but one of the bells is growing.
That's this upper
middle class bell.
And that community
is doing quite well.
But then there's a
thinned out middle.
And a lot of that
thinned out middle
has been push towards
the other bell, which
is a growing lower end,
lower paid services sector.
So we're thinning out the
middle and, therefore,
creating this big economic
inequality problem.
I mean, this is
in a country that
created a democracy
that delivered
staggering social mobility
to its population.
Staggering, unprecedented
in the world, right?
And we're now bringing
that to a close.
We're shutting that down.
What are we doing?
And the social consequences
of this are actually profound.
So the election just told us--
completely disrupted
the Republican Party,
and caused huge disruption
across the board
of all parties.
It's an incredible message,
that just got delivered here
in the United States.
In wrestling with this and
trying to understand and figure
out what to do about it--
I think it's pretty fundamental
to the future of the democracy.
We will avoid this
problem at our peril.
So we've got a loss to
middle income ranks, growing
social inequality, and a whole
post-industrial backlash that's
going on here.
And the question
is, can this idea
of advanced manufacturing,
in some way,
speak to some of this?
So manufacturing
remains a big sector.
It's $1.7 trillion of a
$15 trillion US economy
and employs 12 million in
a workforce of 150 million.
It tends to dominate
the innovation system.
So-- approaching 64% of
scientists and engineers
are employed by
industrial companies.
AUDIENCE: I thought that
back-- you had shown us
before, said that manufacturing
had like two thirds of.
What was it two thirds of?
The two thirds of--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
No, it's not it's--
it's of fortune-- of Standard
and Poor's 500 companies.
It's their-- in other words--
the companies that
make the money.
What portion of their
money comes from production
versus services, right.
And these are the companies that
are delivering for the economy,
frankly.
These are the big companies
that tend to dominate
a lot of employment.
AUDIENCE: So why is there
this big discrepancy
and why isn't anyone
[INAUDIBLE] I mean,
if it's only above 10%
of the poorer economy?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Because manufacturing
is pulling above its
weight in what it delivers.
So the currency of
international trade,
really, is about complex
high value goods.
It's not about services.
That's what this story is.
That's what this
graph on services--
trade surplus versus
goods deficit--
is all about.
The returns are really coming,
predominantly worldwide,
from complex high value goods.
So if you start to reduce your
capability-- and remember,
the United States
is still, by far,
the second largest manufacturing
entity in the world--
there's still a
lot going on here.
80% of US exports are in
this high value, goods area.
Yet, we're running, in 2012, a
$700 billion deficit in goods.
We talked about this a bit.
At the end of-- or,
began to talk about it.
At the end of World War II,
when the US dominated the world
production system,
frankly, we were
able to get a full
spectrum of gains.
So we innovated here,
and we produced here,
and we got the full
benefit of gains
across the entire spectrum.
And then, as Suzanne Burger's
book showed us last week,
we figured out how to
distribute production.
How to separate
production and design--
largely, IT enabled and driven
by the financial services
models--
we figured out how to
separate those two.
And we increasingly began to
try to innovate here and produce
there.
That means that you're
losing a good part
of the full spectrum of gains.
Now, the risk here is that
if innovation is, in fact,
related to production--
particularly,
initial production
of a new technology--
If that's a very
creative, innovative
stage, and you're
shifting that--
then producing there is
going to mean that you're
going to innovate there.
Right?
Because the production
has got to be located
close to the innovation--
for lots of kinds of goods.
Not all goods, but for
lots of kinds of goods.
So the risk we're
running, and that we're
starting to see signs of,
is that producing there
may lead to innovating
there as well.
So, Matthew, in the example
you were giving before about
your-- was it you who raised
the hard technology startup?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
Your friends moving to Shenzhen
to do the rapid scale up,
which Shenzhen is
extremely good at--
logical move.
But they're locating
in a significant part
of their innovation
capability there, now.
And my guess is that when
it comes time for them
to do the next round
of incremental advances
on their good, they're
going to innovate there.
So in a nutshell, that's what's
going on now on a larger scale.
So that affects the
spectrum of gain
that gets distributed
in this country.
So let's suppose that
the US wanted to go back
to production leadership.
It's not going to have
production leadership
in everything, by any means.
But let's say there were
some areas that we could
have production leadership on.
What would we need
to think about?
What will we need to understand?
So the essential argument
that the Production
in the Innovation Economy
study and that the Advanced
Manufacturing
Partnership study came to
was that, historically, shifts
in manufacturing advantage
have stemmed from the
introduction of a combination
of technology advances,
accompanying process
advances, and new business
and organizational models.
If you can combine these, you
can get a production advance.
So we were talking last week
about the remarkable quality
production model that Japan
launched in the 70s and 80s--
on the world.
That's what they did.
They introduced new
technology advances, process,
and new business
models in combination.
It was a remarkable story.
And they captured a significant
portion of world production
in areas like, autos and
consumer electronics.
When the US was developing
its mass production model,
we did the same, and,
exactly, the same thing
occurred-- technology
process business model.
So are there new
technology advances
that scientists and engineers
tell us may be at hand--
that we could use to develop
production innovation?
So how come the US
has such trouble
competing in manufacturing?
There's a bunch
of macro factors,
and I do not want to
underestimate those.
So the US tends to have a
very high valued dollar.
Countries like
Japan and China work
on maintaining a lower
currency valuation.
So they get a competitive
advantage every time they
sell a good.
Right?
That's not to be underestimated.
The tax system in the US tends
to actually, somewhat, favor
components that are imported
rather than components produced
here.
So part of what the
president is attempting
to address in this whole debate
over border adjustability,
is that tax problem.
We also have a tax
system that favors debt
over equity, which tends to
make our companies much more
fragile.
Equity is much more
assured in longer term.
Debt has to be accounted
for and managed
and can hit you in the
short term, very quickly.
It makes our companies
more fragile.
So there's lots of
macro factors here.
But what's new in this
story is an attempt
to put an innovation
story on the table.
Could we bring our still-strong
innovation system to bear,
really, for the
first time, frankly--
on some of these
production challenges?
Now, we did have an episode,
we talked about briefly,
with Sumatech, in the
1980s and early 90s.
A challenge to
semiconductor production
led by Canada and Nissan in--
Canada Nikon in Japan.
And the US organized what was,
in effect, a manufacturing
institute and got its
production process down--
and went to creating
much higher quality
goods that could meet and
match their global competitors.
So that's the one
kind of episode
where we've tried to do
something in the past.
But there's been nothing like
that since the early 90s.
But the point that the
engineers and scientists
seem to be telling
us is that there
looks like there's a bunch of
technology advances, around
which, we could construct
new production paradigms.
Like, what Japan did on quality.
Like, what the US did
on mass production.
And there's lots
of lists of these,
and we'll talk some more in
a minute about some of them.
But maybe, we could do
network centric production.
You know, a mix of
advanced IT RFID sensors,
make every stage of the
production process smart.
From the origin of the
resource, through the entire
lifecycle of the good.
And it talks to you and informs
you about what's happening
and what's going wrong
and how to fix it.
And bring in the mix of advanced
robotics, which is really
co-botics, at this point.
Supercomputing modeling
simulation-- all that stuff.
Could that bear on a
whole new way of doing,
kind of, smart manufacturing--
we could call it.
There are lots of
advances in materials--
it's breathtaking.
We're thinking about
a materials genome,
including, with a lot of
leadership here at MIT--
where we would be
able to, precisely,
design a material to fit the
exact need of a product--
from a molecular
structural point of view.
That's absolutely breathtaking.
Nano fabrication-- all kinds
of possibilities emerging here.
Something called
mass customization--
we may be approaching
the ability
to produce small lots of
goods at the same price
as high volume production.
So that changes
everything, right?
That means, you can
do local production--
like you do local food?
You can do highly
localized production
for highly customized designs.
We would get to participate
in the design process
rather than being a
customer at arm's length.
The history of manufacturing
has been ever more relentless,
to scale up.
This could completely change
the story to scale down--
and much more, in effect,
personalized production
technologies.
So things like 3D printing and
computer driven technologies
and equipment, combined with
a series of other steps,
might enable production of
small lots at the same cost
as production of large lots.
That would be remarkable.
Just-- all kinds
of gains to come
from distribution efficiencies.
All kinds of gains to come
from energy efficiency.
So there's a series of these
potential new paradigms
that could be there, that
could give the US an innovation
advantage and better
be able to compete.
In effect, we'd be
competing on innovation
in historic strength, rather
than competing in areas
that are much more
outside our control.
So what would you do?
Manufacturing is sectoral.
Aerospace is really
different than making cars--
which is really different
than electronics.
But could you launch
technology paradigms
that create benefits
across a series
of these historic sectors?
Well, let's run it.
So across the top are a matrix
of potential new paradigms--
or, series of sectors--
and on the left are new
production paradigms.
How do they match?
Do they serve a lot of sectors?
It looks like they do.
So then you're getting
a multiplier out
of your investment, in a
new production paradigm.
Step 3-- as we talked
earlier, it's no longer
manufacturing or services.
The 21st century
firm is probably
going to combine the two
to create tradable goods
with tradable services.
Step 4, we need to understand
what our competitor nations are
doing.
We just talked about China.
It's really important to
understand the advances
they've come up with--
production-- there's
a lot to learn.
There's deep workforce
issues, and there's
some lessons from the
way Germany does things.
But that's not going
to fit here too well.
Maybe, there are other
models we can utilize.
There is this deep
financing problem.
The financial
services sector has
gone to international
modeling, and the end
of face to face
banking has really
affected small and
midsize manufacturers--
as we talked about earlier.
The focus on core
competency, and driving firms
to go asset light, has
had a profound effect
on industrial strength, overall.
These are big challenges.
A lot of what's happened
in manufacturing
has been driven by
financial services models.
There's no getting around that.
It's hard to change these.
But, maybe, we could
think about ways
of substituting on the
venture capital problem we're
having now-- which is,
that it's, largely, not
available to hard technologies.
So that's kind of the story
on these two readings.
I'll just close with
an image for you
on how to understand
employment in manufacturing.
So think about an hourglass.
And at the top of the hourglass,
here's the production moment.
And there's about 12
million workers there.
Flowing into that
production moment
are all the resources,
suppliers, component makers,
and, as we talked about earlier,
a large part of the R&D system.
That's flowing in to
that production moment.
And then flowing out of
the production moment--
whole distribution system, lots
of services, lots of sales,
lifecycle of the
product, repair--
huge sectors.
The top and the bottom
up the hourglass
are much bigger than
that production moment.
And, through the hourglass,
our value chains of firms--
firms that are
linked to each other.
And when you snap the value
chain, by ending production,
you're messing up
those value chains.
That's what we did
in 2007 and 2008.
We did it for the
entire decade but,
particularly at
that time period.
And it's very hard to
reestablish these value chains.
So the effects of manufacturing
employment are not simply here,
they're throughout
the whole system.
And look, on the other
side of the coin,
the jobs in manufacturing
are not necessarily
going to be here.
They're going to
be in the system
because the system
is so interdependent.
So manufacturing is well
understood to be the strongest
jobs multiplier.
In other words, a
manufacturing job
leads to more jobs because
of these interrelated value
chains, throughout
the whole system.
Service is a much, much
lower job multiplier.
So if you affect
manufacturing, you're
affecting job multiplication
throughout your whole economy.
And the reality is that
the jobs in manufacturing
need to be seen as
part of this system,
not, simply, at the
production environment.
And we've been affecting
the whole system.
Now if you substitute
an imported good
for a US produced
good, then you can
re-establish a good part of
the distribution system repair
and so forth.
But you don't
re-establish the top end.
And you often have a different
value chain arranged for that.
So I tried to come up with an
image that, kind of, explained
what's been going on here.
But I think that's
probably the best
one I've been able
to cook up, in terms
of what the effects have been.
And we've been
living the effects
of snapping those
value chains and firms
by snapping production.
AUDIENCE: So the general
idea I'm getting,
is that we basically
need to develop
new tech that no one
else is prone to be
able to manufacture.
And we need to be able to
manufacture it before they can.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And that's
what we're going to debate.
That's where we're
going to go to next.
So Steph do you want to
lead us off in some Q&A?
It's all yours.
I know you're ready for this.
You've been gunning
for this one.
AUDIENCE: I think
we've all been gunning
for this one, for some time.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And you
can come gunning after me, too,
if you want to-- it's fine.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, I just wanted
say that it is a nice
privilege to be in this room,
to hear all of your resolve.
You're incredibly intelligent.
And as someone who
comes from a low income
immigrant background, to be
a part of the conversation--
to sit at the table is
an immense privilege
and an incredible rarity.
And so we've talked about those
really difficult cliches--
I hope that we remember
our experiences influence
who we are--
and how the family that we
belong to and peers that we
have and how technology
[INAUDIBLE] shift our lives--
in addition to the ways in
which education, our nation,
and the conventional
wisdoms of our culture
have really shaped our
understandings of power
and influence of
English clarity--
with relation to how difficult
the next decade is going
to be for Americans
and for people
around the world who are going
to be affected by the election.
But, remember also, that while
these factors are influencing
us, we have have the ability to
influence these factors back.
I just wanted to take a
second to remember that.
The second thing that I
wanted to ensure to address
was something that I spoke
with Bill about last week--
it was in the context of Japan--
and that's, the role of mental
health in the workforce.
And Japan has one of the
highest rates of suicide
amongst labor workforce.
And that has only been
increasing over the last two
decades.
And in particular, because
of the strenuous hours
that workers are
forced to attain--
in addition to the
enormous pressures
to work for very
influential firms.
In addition to the fact
that most of them say,
I want a firm,
their whole life--
only switching if they're
immensely uncomfortable
and get a better position.
Which, is obviously a
rarity in our society.
And to that point, the
flip side of the story
is that in the United
States, there's
also been a sharp
increase in suicide
amongst white population.
In particular,
white rural peoples.
And there is a study that came
out last year in The Washington
Post, where in February 2016--
only a couple of months
before the election--
they made a very good point
about talking about how
rural women had an increase
in suicide rates from 47%
in the last 10 years--
more than urban women.
So rural women are
disproportionately
experiencing the impacts of
the loss of manufacturing
capabilities and the loss
of [INAUDIBLE] dynamism
in production because they
are the ones who have to,
ultimately, bear the brunt
of the home economics.
And then, in addition
to that-- white suicide,
generally, has only
decreased 1% since 1995.
Whereas, suicide rates amongst
Hispanics and African-Americans
were two of the groups
surveyed and have decreased
over 47% in the last 20 years.
So the fact is, that in addition
to that-- in the last decade,
there's actually been an
increase in white suicide
as well.
In particular, after
2007, amongst white men.
And so white men are now
independent of people
being targeted for homophobia,
transphobia, et cetera.
White men, and especially
middle aged white men,
are the ones who are most at
risk of committing suicide--
as a result of the downturn
in the American economy.
So the 2007 crisis is
a strong correlation
with the increase of
suicide amongst white males.
So consider, these are very real
issues that we're dealing with.
And I think I was
sharing with Bill
that one of the difficulties
of having this conversation--
I think, in this room, and
more across our homelives
and our areas of
influence, is that I think
it can be very hard
to put ourselves
in the shoes of the
American manufacturer who
has lost their job.
It can be hard to understand the
implications of what it means
to be a person who is now facing
a job loss or the extinction
of their job opportunities.
And, now, here we are
talking about the potential
for retraining programs and
what does that look like.
And what opportunity will
they have in the next decade
and the next generation?
And for myself, a moment where I
felt this very intimately was--
maybe, two weeks ago when I
was studying for my CS111 p-set
that's undertaking
learning to code in Python.
And I'm doing it because
I want to learn more
about technology because
that's my concentration.
And here I am having
a panic attack
at 10:00 PM on a Saturday
night because I'm trying
to figure out how to code.
And I realize that this is
not my livelihood on the line.
It's just me trying to
learn something new just
because I enjoy it.
So I hope that we take the
spirit of understanding
and compassion in trying to
figure out how easily we can
negotiate between protecting the
communities that matter to us--
as well as maintaining
American competitiveness
and collaboration
on a global level.
And, at the same
time, remembering
the immense difficulties
that people in our country
are facing.
And, at the same
time, how difficult
it is for the United
States because we're
in a compromised position--
because so much of our economy
has been built on
the backs of laborers
in developing countries.
So human rights exploitation
is not something
that we directly talk
about in this course.
But it's certainly
something that is relevant.
So I hope that as we
enter this discussion,
we keep all of those
factors in mind.
Again, approaching this with
an open heart and open mind
and being to critically assess
these very difficult questions
that we will have to
deal with as emerging
leaders in the field.
And with that--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Steph,
let me add something
to your powerful points.
We've talked in significant part
of the effect of manufacturing
decline on white males.
Those were the data points
that I brought to you.
But we need to remember
here, something
that's been going on that's
every bit as powerful.
In that post-World War II era--
during World War II and
that post-World War II era
the African-American
community in the south
goes to great diaspora
and moves north
to seek an opportunity to
break in the middle class
with these industrial jobs.
And it's a moment
of incredible hope.
There's actually a path forward
with these well-paid industrial
jobs.
And that community enters
areas like the auto-sector
in significant numbers.
And that's going to
be the path ahead.
And those hopes, in
significant part,
have now been totally wrecked.
And we've got all over the
country these shell cities.
Think about Detroit.
Think what's
happened in Detroit.
This is not simply a white,
working class problem;
this is a much deeper
problem in our society
that we're now just starting
to think about and confront.
So I just wanted to add
that on top of your picture.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I think
there's a lot to be said,
I think, for the
differentiation or the impact.
The other point I
would add to that
would also be the role
of the exploitation
of immigrant communities
over all areas,
in particular that benefit off
of the manufacturing sector.
For example, so if my family
members worked at meat packing
plants in Nebraska, others
will get production plants
in other parts of Nebraska.
And my life looks very
different than theirs
just because I got
really lucky and got
to go to school in Texas.
So I invested in me,
got to go to Wellesley
and my life is
different from theirs.
So as we think about the
nuances of the implications
on this election, the first
question I wanted to start off
was actually Luyao was talking
about earlier, specifically
on this question of the
America First framework.
You mentioned how
far can we see firms
as customers who use their
investment decisions as votes
for different
economies and markets.
Outsourcing US firms can be seen
as a reduced marginal utility
of manufacturing investment.
So in a world in which we
understand America's firms
as in investing in
other countries,
what does this say about their
values as in your opinion?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Now,
that was a big question.
That was big.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: In fact
the word huge comes to mind.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: What does it
say about our companies
because they value profits?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
still a question of what
to do to make the firms--
to attract the firms back
to the US.
I think I'm not--
I've only started to follow
US politics after I came here.
[INAUDIBLE] Trump would
propose how to do this,
telling them not to [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me
just add a statistic, Luyao,
to what you're saying.
Like weekly job churn
in the United States,
the number of jobs lost,
and acquired, 75,000.
Right?
Staggering.
So if you've got the
president on the phone
twice a month saving 200 jobs,
you haven't done anything.
These are systems issues,
deeply etched into the system
we've got, and those
are arguably the issues
we need to tackle.
AUDIENCE: I don't know how
much you can blame corporations
for these decisions in general,
at least for larger ones.
They're subject to their
shareholders, which
is, their shareholders
will want returns,
but if you could get a large
group of shareholders that
said, we want you to make less
money and build in America
or we're all going to sell
and your company is going
to lose all its value,
then they would actually
change something.
But I feel like it's kind of
like a grassroots movement that
would be necessary,
like the idea
behind the divestment movement
is to kind of encourage that.
But even those groups, while
they are growing inside
are too small to really make
a big difference right now.
So we'd have to come from like--
AUDIENCE: Another
thing too, even
if you make all the choices,
like the CEO of the company,
and you get sued if your
stock drops too much.
So it's like, yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] thinks that he
would ultimately [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So thank you.
Appealing to corporate
goodwill to reduce profits
is probably completely
unworkable, right?
So what are the other--
what other territory
can we work in?
AUDIENCE: The other
things that you could
do-- you give them incentives.
So either, for example,
manufacturing in China--
make it less attractive.
Or make manufacturing
more attractive.
So in order to make
it less attractive,
manufacturing in China,
you could [INAUDIBLE]
like trade tariffs.
We don't have any tariffs
with China, do we?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, both countries
are part of the World
Trade agreement.
So there are modest
tariffs remaining.
But it turns out to be a much
more complicated global system
than simply the way
tariffs operate.
AUDIENCE: Like one thing
is never going to fix this.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And look, the
multinationals have
to be in all the big markets.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right?
If you're running a
multinational that's only,
you know, selling
into one continent
rather than four or five, you've
got a heck of a problem, right?
So you're going to need to
be where your markets are.
So what else can we do?
AUDIENCE: I think going off
that idea of getting incentives,
I think kind of
relaxing maybe tax
rates on a lot of corporations,
like overseas funds,
could be an interesting
way to approach it.
Like right now, I'm taking a
tax class from Michelle Hanlon,
and she's really behind the idea
that the overseas, the 40% tax
rate that would be
implied, or sorry,
levied on anything
that comes back
into the US, which
could be feeding
economic growth,
creation of jobs,
perhaps fuel more
pursuits here in America--
those are just staying
stagnant pretty much overseas,
because those are tax havens.
And that's how they
can best maximize
the game of not
paying so many taxes
and still having a lot of
reserves for their company
to show the profits.
But obviously,
controversial, and tax policy
takes a long time to change.
AUDIENCE: Martin, do you have
a comment about tax policy
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Slightly [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just going to say,
it's something that--
OK, as a business person,
I feel like it's definitely
a political spectrum,
the political side that
needs to deal with this issue.
But also, as somebody
who knows history well,
I'm very doubtful
of politicians that
have to get funded every four
years or two years by somebody.
And I just don't think it's
a great system that way,
because people have this
short term thinking,
and then most likely
will be somebody
with corporate interests
or corporate ties,
and lobbying will be a effect.
And so that's-- that's the thing
that I think is a big issue.
AUDIENCE: But just maybe
to clarify a little bit--
so I understood [INAUDIBLE].
Instead of these offshore
tax havens, [INAUDIBLE]
taxes levied for leaving
interest offshore,
and you want to
bring those assets,
and kind of make it more
attractive to keep your money
and let it be taxed here
by relaxing these rates?
AUDIENCE: Mmhm.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: Anybody have any
more comments about tax havens?
AUDIENCE: Oh.
You could take the
other route, and rather
than just get rid of the
taxes, which like you said,
could create a lot of
jobs and a lot of wealth,
rather than just
reduce them, why not
just make it so that these tax
havens are impossible to use?
Which should be illegal, but--
AUDIENCE: Is that
politically possible, though?
AUDIENCE: Probably not.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Look.
I mean, the new
administration is,
as I mentioned
earlier, pushing hard
on border adjustability,
which frankly,
is the system virtually
every other country has.
It's going to be really hard
politically to get that done.
And it's also pushing hard on a
new way of treating debt versus
equity in the tax system.
Those two pieces alone could
be actually fairly significant
if they're able to do them.
You know, we'll see.
But Steph, go back to
some of the questions
that you've got ready--
the arsenal that you've
got waiting for us.
AUDIENCE: She's like,
all right, let's go.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
actually [INAUDIBLE]..
So I thought that this was
a-- this one's from Beth.
And I thought that this was
a really important question,
in particular because
of the group of people
that's assembled here.
She asks, manufacturing
is no longer
seen as a cool or innovative
job by many students,
especially at MIT.
As startups in Silicon
Valley attract talent,
how can these
perceptions be altered?
AUDIENCE: This is really funny.
I was just talking
with a friend of mine
from another school about this.
We were watching Saturday
Night Live, I think,
and a GE commercial came on.
And we commented how literally,
from the last few years,
all of the GE
commercials have not
been about, buy our product.
They've been, please
come work for us.
So they had this slew
of them that were like--
I don't know if you
guys have seen them,
but there was like, the young
kid who goes to his parents
and says, I got a job
at GE, or to his friend,
I got a job at GE.
I'm gonna be writing code.
The jig is the world.
And his parents are
struggling to see that
as an interesting thing,
because in their minds,
GE is the big hammer.
They build the big machinery,
and it's very mechanical,
old manufacturing style to them.
And then there was a GE
commercial that just came out
recently, the
[INAUDIBLE] one, that
was talking about how they
have this new initiative
to encourage, to get a
higher number of women
in technical jobs
by 2020, I think.
But just-- yeah, I
think it's definitely
a very pervasive attitude.
And maybe some of
these older giants
are starting to
take note of that
as they're looking at their
workforce age dwindling.
AUDIENCE: If I can
ask you a followup--
I know in the reading, it
talked about the importance
of working in the manufacturing
plant for engineers to really
get a sense innovation
capacity in production.
Could you talk a
little bit about how
you might feel if you had
to go to a production plant
to start off your career?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No, I agree with
previous sentiments
that other people have
expressed regarding that.
I think it's very important
for engineers, or people
who work strictly
at design or maybe,
you know, with a CAD
program for the majority
of their career
to see how things
work on the ground floor.
I had an internship
last summer where--
I wasn't working
on this project.
But the person who
was paired with me
on the same project,
her entire summer
was spent designing a wheel.
Not just one wheel--
it was a filter wheel.
It was a very complicated
piece of machinery.
But it was all
very computer-based
and very design-based.
But she spent half
the summer shadowing
the guy in the machine
shop who was actually
going to be making the wheel.
And this ended up
motivating so many
of her design requirements
and decisions.
And I think, at least from
an engineering perspective,
it's very important
to understand
how that works so that
you can not forge ahead
beyond the capabilities
that exist,
and take advantage of
the innovation that's
happening on the factory floor.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And as we talked
about last week,
one of the things
that Japan figured out
in its highly innovative
production process
towards quality was not
separating the engineering
workforce from the
factory floor workforce,
but really integrating
them, right?
And the engineering
community would come on,
and its first round of
jobs was to understand
how the factory floor operated.
So Germany is famous for this.
But when there's a problem, when
there's a production problem,
a swarm forms in these
Mittelstand firms.
The engineers and the
highly educated workforce
team up and are working the
thing out together, right?
That happens less
than the US system.
So this kind of
integration of the design
team and the production
team is something
that has been organized in
countries like Japan and--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] consulting
firms just sort of build
that gap.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Oh, yeah.
Right.
I'm sure they do.
McKenzie is right there on
the factory floor, right?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, and what's
fascinating is-- at MIT--
have any of you guys
taken classes at D-Lab?
AUDIENCE: No.
But they've helped
me build some stuff.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
So they're really big advocates
of creative capacity building
and co-creation, so
building products
for communities in
developing countries
with those communities.
And I think it's
been fascinating
that MIT is at the forefront of
that for developing countries.
And yet--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We've got a
developing country right here.
AUDIENCE: Right.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right?
AUDIENCE: I think
companies, particularly
like the German style sort
of rotational programs
for these engineers, making
sure that they get experience
on the factory floor--
I think, I want to say
chemical production plants-- so
people who graduate with
chemical engineering
degrees [INAUDIBLE]
oil pipelines,
they do this pretty well.
So they go and they rotate
and they see the oil pipelines
and stuff like that,
so if they have
to build these complex parts
in front of the computer,
they go to the site and go
and see what's going on.
I feel like they have
those rotational programs
for the established--
I'm going to use
chemical engineering
firms, because that's
where I've heard the most.
But there is this sentiment
that maybe touring these factory
floors and actually seeing
what you're building
is going to be really important.
But I think the only
other rotational programs
that I hear about, when people
do internships like this,
is in I want to say finance.
They do this very well.
They rotate you in
different sectors.
I think Goldman-- all the big
banks have rotational programs,
where you have your
first two or three years.
And Visa does it as well.
Everybody does it.
But you basically
spend a year or two
working with a particular
team with a particular focus.
And then you tour all up
and down the pipeline.
So if it's asset management,
you go top to bottom.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Excellent.
So if you transition
and make sure
that these internships that
people are getting sort of
do more of that, and kind
of mimic those models,
where you rotate around
and see what's available,
integrating those
pipelines, then you'll
have a better idea of what
you're actually engineering for
and what these design
processes are actually
supposed to look like
within manufacturing.
AUDIENCE: I want to call on Max.
AUDIENCE: So I've been
thinking a couple things.
One would be that that
approach of forcing engineers
to actually to basically
get their hands dirty--
I feel like it would make
them happier, because--
AUDIENCE: Well, a lot of
the people [INAUDIBLE]..
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: A lot
of the people that
go into engineering, they're
the kids who played with LEGOs.
And they thought, oh, this
is what the engineering's
going to be like.
And then they find out it's a
bunch of CAD drawings and Excel
spreadsheets.
And they're just like, wow, this
is isn't exactly satisfying.
I can't speak to
everyone's experience.
I can speak to mine.
And I know that was
one of my reactions.
It's still like, yeah,
you're designing something
that's changing the world.
But when it comes down to it,
it's still all on a computer.
You're staring at a computer
for eight hours a day.
And as other people
were saying, yeah,
it definitely gives
people exposure
to concepts like
machine tolerance
and the ability for, I don't
know-- you realize that, hey,
I can't design something that
has design specifications
within a femtometer.
That's 10 to the
negative 15 meters.
It's 15, right?
I think it's 15.
AUDIENCE: It's very small.
AUDIENCE: It's small.
So yeah, I generally agree
with the general sentiment.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Max, how
pervasive is the maker movement
now at MIT?
I mean, I think we have
some 40 maker spaces.
And Professor Marty
Culpepper's or makers
are obviously a
very talented guy.
AUDIENCE: I do know that
a couple of professors
in the nuclear department are
trying to design a maker space.
They're trying to get
some support together,
some funding together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Mike Short.
AUDIENCE: Mike Short?
How do you know Mike Short?
AUDIENCE: I study nuclear.
AUDIENCE: Beth, I know that
you wanted to respond to that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you
respond to [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: I probably
said something horrible.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
I just think-- my view
of a lot of MIT students
is that we've been prepared is
like white collar engineers.
We're people who want to
go straight to the office.
And I think part of it's good.
We want to be leaders.
We want to be
tackling big projects.
But we also view
ourselves as not
wanting to get into the
nitty-gritty, out in the FRCs
in the field, doing the hardcore
engineering-- that we've
kind of surpassed
that and should
be doing higher and
better things than that.
And then kind of
unrelated to that--
well, somewhat related,
is demographic change,
but changes in
people's preferences.
I know, personally,
I was offered
a job in somewhat
manufacturing in kind
of the middle of nowhere.
And so I have a strong
preference to live in a city.
And so that has made me
less likely to [INAUDIBLE]
manufacturing outside.
And there's not really
the opportunities to--
I mean, there are
some opportunities
to have like the urban lifestyle
and also work in manufacturing.
But that's becoming
less and less possible.
AUDIENCE: I think something I've
noticed amongst our responses--
and well, we aren't
talking particularly
about the skilled workforce.
So I was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit more
about what training programs or
what this experience might look
time for the, quote unquote,
unskilled workforce,
or the non
college-educated crowd,
as we are going to
be transitioning
to a question about
that momentarily.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So in my hometown, we're just
by a really large shipyard.
And so there's a pretty
strong apprenticeship program
that a bunch of kids
are going to school.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Where is that, Beth?
AUDIENCE: It's the
Newport News Shipyard.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
That's what I thought.
AUDIENCE: And so I've
seen that a lot of people
that I know from
high school who have
had very successful points
in their careers now.
They finished their
apprenticeship program
and are now full-time
employees of the shipyard.
And that does seem to be an
exception rather than a rule.
And it seems-- it is very
much like the shipyard runs
it itself.
It's not like wider movement.
And it's been really, I think,
successful for them as well
in having a continuous
skilled workforce,
and repeating that
elsewhere seems
like it could be a good idea.
AUDIENCE: So this is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I want
to hear from Kevin.
He actually wants to
go into manufacturing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: First of all, I
don't know about my last year.
So before this semester, I
was actually taking time off.
And for about a year, I worked
as a manufacturing operations
manager at a digital
printing company.
It was a small
startup, kind of new.
But for the first
two or three weeks,
they had me learn every
bit of the process,
from picking out access
material by hand,
to learning all
their new software,
to understanding how the big
wide format printers work,
setting up the conveyor
oven with the owners--
every part of the process.
And I can definitely
say that helped a lot
in my understanding of
being able to manage
the employees in the
different departments--
the shipping, the
art department, all
that-- because I knew it worked.
I was in touch with them.
I was in touch
with the employees.
At the meetings we had, it
was just the owners and me.
It was the owners.
There was someone would
be there from shipping.
Someone some would
be there from art.
And everybody would say,
look, this is great,
we would love to get
orders out this fast,
but shipping can't do it
because of these capabilities.
And next week,
we'd make a change
that would make that possible.
Going back to Beth's point about
manufacturing not being cool--
this is just my
opinion, but I really
don't want to kiss up to
someone for funding for an idea.
Right?
I am very happy learning
every bit of process
in the manufacturing
operation, and then
being able to lead that.
And I definitely enjoyed
that the last year, which
is why it just kind of
reaffirms my decision
to go into manufacturing
after I graduate.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Kevin,
you're going to save us all.
AUDIENCE: That's the plan.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
All right.
You get one more
question, Steph,
because then I've got to
get to the last reading,
because the clock is upon us.
AUDIENCE: Oh, this
is so stressful.
So I'll say, I think--
there it a question that
I'll mention that we will not
get to debate, but I hope
that everyone sort of
reflects on this point, which
is a point that Chris raised.
She says, how do we expect
domestic policy, job creation,
and manufacturing to change
under Trump's administration?
Obviously, that's something
that we'll sort of witness,
unfortunately, or--
no value judgments here.
But I do think it was
important to raise that is
a reality, as we all know.
The question that I really want
us to flush out is from Lily.
And she says, would this
not be an ideal time
for a very effective
national advertising
campaign promoting
technical schools
and starting to promote
technical skills?
If the administration intends to
create increased manufacturing
jobs, won't it need a ready
workforce in a few years?
AUDIENCE: I'll jump in on that.
I think, yeah, it's
definitely a good time.
I think we're kind of in
a pseudo college bubble--
not to say that
college isn't valuable.
But it's not proportionate
to the amount of people we
need in the economy for jobs.
So you need blue
collar people that
would be educated at a higher
university and grad students.
And so there is a huge
divide in that people just
don't go with the
blue collar jobs
because they don't
seem valuable.
So a lot of it is based on
is this a valuable profession
for me to go into,
especially because there
aer some people
who, if they want
to get very practical, street
smart, manufacturing skills,
they might want to go
work in manufacturing
versus actually studying a
mechanical engineering degree.
And so it's how do you
make those jobs valuable,
but also a good use
of people's time.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thinking about that,
[INAUDIBLE] case study in
education [INAUDIBLE]
high school.
If you look at Sweden's
education system versus the US,
and in Sweden, any
high school teacher
needs to have a master's degree.
And becoming a teacher, a high
school teacher, is like the job
that people want to enter.
And it just makes me
think about and consider
how much of our
perception of a job
and how much demand there is
for certain jobs is flexible.
And it's not necessarily--
well, the value you add
is as perceived by people
in the country, right?
So would it help even
just to have a PR campaign
for manufacturing jobs?
And would that even
be enough to shift
people's behavior towards it?
AUDIENCE: But I mean,
that's a PR [INAUDIBLE]..
And I had dinner
with this guy who's
the president of an energy
company in Australia.
And he talked a lot
about credibility,
not just being credible.
So the GE commercial, you could
hear it and see, oh, yeah,
well, I don't really trust it.
I don't believe it, because I
know you're marketing to me.
Right?
And this is a big thing
business, especially today,
because people can
sense bullshit, right?
It's just like,
yeah, it's not real,
because you used to
be like, oh, yeah,
safety's a really big priority.
And he would go--
he was part of this mining
slash energy company with oil.
And he would go
in and he wouldn't
wear his safety equipment.
And he would go on the
job and in the field
and everyone would see him
not wearing safety equipment.
And then he'd go and push for--
oh, yeah, let's do--
we need to be very safe, guys.
And they're like,
well, you're the boss,
and you never do any of this.
Why should I listen to you?
So it's like, how do you do
it in a very credible way
that people can actually see
people that are successful?
Because right now, who do
you see as successful, right?
It's mostly some
college educated--
I don't want to say white male,
but it's definitely not women
and minorities, really.
Yeah.
Good point.
AUDIENCE: Well, I had
a lot of considerations
going into this question.
One is, is wistfulness.
or hopefulness.
I just wish that,
with the energy that
was generated during the
election and the promise
of jobs, and you saw
a lot of people--
I think there's anger,
but also hopefulness.
Like yes, we're going to
bring back manufacturing jobs.
So then build on that.
Identify-- it would be excellent
if the administration could
pinpoint what sorts
of sectors they
want to promote and
incentivize, and then
create an advertising campaign.
I know when I was younger,
I used to see the--
I think the military divisions
have really excellent
advertising campaigns.
I saw it, the Air Force,
and be like, oh, man, I
want to go into the Air Force.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Have you seen
[INAUDIBLE] Marine commercial?
Have you been targeted
on YouTube yet?
It's so good.
AUDIENCE: I don't watch
enough TV these days.
But I think that this would be
an opportune time to do that,
so that if you generate
manufacturing jobs
over the next couple of years,
as they promised or intended--
and more manufacturing
jobs have come back
over the last few
years, as we've seen.
So then have that
ready workforce.
Also, I'm from a rural area,
a farming area in Missouri,
where a lot of jobs have been
lost over the last decade.
Most of the people I
went to school with
don't have the money to go
to a four-year university,
and they don't have the money to
not make money for four years.
So something that's more
short term, like a one-year,
a two-year technical
program is much more in line
with what they're able to do.
Those were the considerations.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And then I do think what
else needs to be considered
is what exactly would we
recommend to train people
in at this point?
What are the--
because you don't want
to train a bunch of
people in something
that is no longer useful
in five or 10 years.
So should we be teaching
people how to code?
Should there be programs
in using complex robots?
I don't know what to expect.
And I think that's a challenge.
AUDIENCE: No, it
should be targeted.
Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I spent
some time with Sanjay Sarma
earlier this afternoon.
And he's a--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what does he do?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
He's a professor
of mechanical
engineering, and has
spent a lot of time creating
a lot of the RFID capability,
and did a lot of work
in manufacturing.
But he's leading MIT's
online education efforts.
So he leads MITx and the
Office of Digital Learning ODL.
So that was his question.
We can take these new
platforms we've built,
and they could be valuable.
They could be new assets.
And we could create
blended learning models
with community
colleges, for example.
But what is the content
of the education?
How do we figure that out?
Right?
And it's really a big,
important question.
And that's his central
question at this point.
He's ready to do it.
But he's got to
figure out a process
by which to get to the
answers of what are the most
critical skills to educate for?
Obviously, they're going to
vary to some extent by sector.
But that's a really
big question.
So Steph, give us
a closing comment.
AUDIENCE: I am
prepared for this.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I know you are.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The haircut-- yeah,
this is what I want to study,
right?
This is what I love.
And I think in
particular [INAUDIBLE]
I was doing research that
was funded by [INAUDIBLE]
here at MIT D Lab, Wellesley,
and some organizations
in Thailand to research
precisely how you do
creative capacity building and
increase civic participation
and innovation in ways
that really support
collaboration and are
responsive and understanding
of the political and
economic contexts.
Right?
And we did this research in
two villages in Thailand.
And I think preliminarily,
the most important outcomes
of this study were realizing
that a lot of technologies
fade rather quickly, right?
They're no longer useful.
They become outdated.
They fail to run.
And I think we do
a really great job
of studying this in
the developing world
when we ship tools
to other places
about how they're
no longer modular.
And I think we could apply that
sort of same line of reasoning
here to the United States about
the ways in which we treat
critical thinking education
and ways in which we make
our education systems
modular and understandable
for all at every point,
rather than teaching
particular skills that may be
outdated, because then they'll
end up in crises like I had
two Saturdays ago-- crying
in my room, saying, why
can't I get this problem?
And I don't know that the
kind of support system that's
necessary for an initiative
such as blended learning
is [INAUDIBLE] currently.
And that's why I think it's
so important to really assess
cultural factors, and
also questions of support
as we move forward with how
to improve the innovation
and manufacturing harmony.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
Thank you.
All right.
So I'm going to just summarize
this closing reading.
We've talked a lot
about the problems.
This has been one
attempt at a fix.
So these two reports
came out in 2012, 2014.
They were prepared
by a collaboration
between major industry CEOs
and a whole range of sectors,
and a group of
university presidents
who had particularly strong
engineering links, including
MIT's president.
So both Susan Hockfield at MIT
and Rafael Reif at MIT were
both co-chairs,
university co-chairs,
of these two different reports--
Susan for the 2012 one,
Rafael for the 2014 one.
So there's been a very major
focus on these issues at MIT.
MIT did the production and
the innovation economy.
It was, frankly, educating
the administration
of what the issues were.
And then, surprise, the
Obama administration
came back and said, all
right, put your money
where your mouth is, and help
us pull these reports together.
So I had the privilege
of being part
of a delegation of MIT folks
to help in preparing these.
And it was a
fascinating experience.
So there were essentially
four recommendations
that came out of these reports.
There are transformative
technologies.
And could we develop, to
achieve these transformative
technologies and production,
technology strategies that
were linked to the R&D system?
Could we implement
manufacturing institutes
and network the
organized around these
transformative technologies?
Could we have, as part of the
role of these manufacturing
institutes, they would play a
role in demand-driven workforce
solutions?
And then finally, could we
develop a technology scale-up
policy to deal with
this scale-up problem?
So these reports really
focused on this stuff.
They argued that we need
innovation-based efficiency
gains to compete with lower
cost, lower wage nations.
There's no substitute for that.
The macro factors
don't necessarily
give this, those solutions.
We've got to put the innovation
system on this problem.
Right?
There's no getting around it.
It's time.
So there's 14 advanced
manufacturing institutes now.
They've been set up
all over the country.
They are collaborative.
They are industry,
university, government.
They are federal
government seed funding,
but often overmatched by
industry with seed funding
as well from state and
sometimes regional governments.
They have a big test bed roll.
So they bring in the small
and mid-sized manufacturers
and put them in as part
of the innovation system.
Right?
They're connecting the small
and large manufacturers, just as
in the German fraunhofer model.
They have a big test bed role
in testing technologies out so
that a small manufacturer would
know how to play with them,
know how to work with them.
And then they're organized
around these potential new
production paradigms.
They're cost-shared, as I said,
between the federal government
industry and the
state government.
So they're very collaborative.
An example-- what does advanced
manufacturing technology
look like?
Here's a printed car.
Right?
Concept to print, six
weeks, 500 parts--
took 24 hours to print this.
That's a Shelby Cobra.
It's electric.
It's battery-powered.
Pretty interesting, right?
It gives us some idea of what
some of these capabilities
are going to look like.
What's the stage
that the institutes
are supposed to address?
And we've seen designs like
this earlier in the class.
But we've got basic
R&D, government support
of universities, a gap here,
and then a private sector role.
And the gap occurs--
basic research,
proof of concept,
then actual undertaking, kind
of the initial production
stage at a lab kind
of level, capacity
to produce the advanced
prototype, and the capability,
really about here, to operate
in a production environment,
bring the technology
to production.
That's where the gap is.
It's in these stages here.
Right?
There's a missing link
in the innovation system.
Remember, we talked
about doing a gap
analysis of the innovation
system and filling the gaps in?
That's exactly what
these institutes
are attempting to undertake.
And here's the
organization of them.
This is a very
complex organization.
Right?
So you've got an institute,
which has prototype labs.
It has shops.
It has research facilities.
It's got a computerized lab
for simulation and modeling.
These are shared use facilities,
where small and large firms
can collaborate together.
They're bringing in universities
for engineering capability
from the university level to
help in the innovation stage
and technology development.
They're bringing in community
colleges on the workforce
development side.
Over here, they're bringing
in large manufacturing
firms, small and mid-sized.
And a number of
them are starting
to think now about startups.
How do we get them
into this mix?
And then the support
system-- federal, state,
and local-- and economic
development organizations
are all feeding in here.
And then above this, we have
14 of these institutes now.
Could we create
a network of them
so that we get learning
across the system?
So that's essentially the
organizational design.
It's a very complex model.
What does an R&D
agency typically do?
It gives an award of $300,000
to a principal investigator.
As a Defense Department
official told me,
this is like standing
up a country.
You've got literally
more than 100 actors
involved in these
manufacturing institutes.
How do you coordinate them?
How do you pull these
things together?
We've never tried to do
anything as complicated
as this in the R&D system.
It's a real challenge.
So this is the first group
of manufacturing institutes.
You can see that they're pretty
distributed across the country.
And then we've had
five more institutes
since these were stood up.
Here's what we're working on.
These are the territories
of advanced manufacturing.
So we've got 3D, printing
digital manufacturing
and design, lightweight and
modern metals, next generation
power electronics, which
is largely wide band gap
semiconductor--
completely changes
power electronics,
but a lot of other things too--
advanced composites, photonics,
flexible hybrid electronics.
MIT is leading the advanced
fiber institute, which
is completely revolutionary.
The US lost the textile
sector ages ago.
So this is an idea, bringing
entirely new functionality
into fiber and textiles.
So the idea here--
my shirt is my cell phone.
My coat is my laptop.
It's just full of
communication fiber, right?
But why can't you put a whole
new level of functionality
into fibers and textiles, a
whole kind of new utility,
and a completely
invented sector?
As Yoel Fink, who's
head of that institute,
reminded me on many occasions,
and his colleagues as well,
said, Egypt came up with
cotton about 4,000 years ago.
And that's about the last
big thing that happened.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right?
So this crowd is completely
trying to rethink--
and they've got a
fascinating mix.
They've got Apple in there.
And then they've
got Nike and Adidas.
got Under Armor.
And then they've got a
bunch of textile firms
that still remain in the US.
And then they've got
fashion design shops.
And it's a really
interesting mix
as they try to rethink
an entire sector.
Smart men-- I'm sorry.
Go ahead, Max.
AUDIENCE: What is next
gen power electronics?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: If you did
wide band gap semiconductor,
you lose--
you have much more efficiency
in the power connections.
And you have much
less power loss
in a switching process
or a connection process.
Right?
So it requires a new
kind of semiconductor
to undertake this.
But it could be in
everything, and very perfect
pervasive, huge power
savings, much more efficiency
in production as a result.
There's five more
institutes that
were named at the very end
of 2016, beginning of 2017--
Bioengineering for Regenerative
Medicine, Assistive Robotics,
Modular Chemical Process
Intensification--
in other words, rethinking
the whole chemical engineering
process system to radically
reduce the number of stages--
Sustainable
Remanufacturing Recycling.
And then the
Department of Commerce
had an open competition,
and they came up
with biopharma manufacturing.
There are major new advances
in biopharma manufacturing
for continuous production.
So it's a very interesting list.
Right?
What's interesting
about the US list
is that it covers a
wide range of stuff,
where there are
potential advances it
could be quite powerful.
Some are going to work.
Some are going to fail.
But overall, it's a
pretty interesting model.
If we could get these
technologies stood up
and a workforce that's
ready to use them,
then you really might have
something pretty significant.
And as you remember from that
matrix chart I had before,
these are designed to
stretch across a whole series
of industries, not
just a single industry.
Beth?
AUDIENCE: Are these
vulnerable to being cut?
Or right now, they
have secure funding?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I'm definitely worried.
We'll see.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: The
funding's by no means secure.
But Congress has
passed legislation
supporting this on a
completely bipartisan basis.
There are strong advocates
in both parties for these.
Senator Blunt from Missouri
is a very strong advocate
for example, has been a
real champion of this stuff.
So there's a lot of
Congressional support
here, mainly because
members of Congress
are seeing what's been
happening in their Congressional
districts.
So I think this is a
more survivable model.
And what's wrong with this?
I mean, this is a total
public-private partnership
with the private sector
dominating and leading
and making by far the largest
contribution to the funding.
Right?
So this is not some
federal subsidy program.
This is very cost-shared.
So I think it may be survivable.
We'll see.
MIT is in nine of these 14
manufacturing institutes
in one way or the other.
We're very active in about
four and leading on one.
So there's now a whole community
at MIT of leading researchers
that's into this stuff.
And MIT had not been in
this area for a long time.
It just wasn't-- you didn't get
R&D funding for manufacturing.
Right?
This is a whole new
kind of territory.
So we'll see.
Hopefully, it'll
work for you, Kevin.
Maybe some others.
AUDIENCE: We just
answered our last debate.
This is what we designed the
technical training programs
around.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.